hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with Emily Ekins the
polling director of The Reason
Foundation and a PhD student at UCLA
Emily thanks for talking to us good to
be with you we've got a polling project
of Reason Foundation now tell us what
we're doing well we are doing a
quarterly national poll serving public
opinion on a variety of issues many of
which will be very interesting to the
reason audience what are some of the
topics that future polls are going to go
into some of those include topics about
drug policy immigration entitlement
reform and even you know what it what is
the public learn since the financial
crisis in 2008 and my understanding is
that our poll is our polls are going to
be showing not just what people think
but how or why they think that exactly
that's an itch that we hope to really
focus on is not just what people think
but why they think it and also allow for
a great deal of transparency in the
results we plan to have all of our data
available online publicly available
people can download it look at it for
themselves and be able to analyze it
right okay well that sounds great and in
keeping with the foundation the magazine
the websites interest in kind of open
source group I don't want to say
groupthink but distributed intelligence
what was the before we go into the
results of the first poll what was the
sample size and had how was the poll
conducted so we conducted a telephone
survey contacting both mobile and
landline phones 1,200 adults throughout
the US and this poll has a margin of
error of about three percent the big
finding or one of the big findings is
that people are concerned about debt
what what was going on that yes we found
that ninety six percent of americans
believe that cutting the national debt
is important in fact sixty-nine percent
said it was very important so oh that's
on their minds how what did you find out
about how they
wanna address the debt how do they want
to deal with yes we found that
seventy-four percent of Americans wanted
to implement a spending cap a government
spending cap which means that the
government would not be allowed to spend
more than it takes in a given year so
that would address that the growth of
the national debt but in terms of
dealing with the deficit as it is today
sixty-two percent wanted to target
reducing spending so of that about
sixteen percent want to temper reducing
spending with minimal tax increases and
forty-five percent opposed tax increases
all together so there is not I mean
people are interested in reducing the
debt and reducing deficit spending on an
annual basis and they're they're looking
more towards trimming spending rather
than hiking taxes according to this poll
that is what we found what more broadly
you have some questions about kind of
reform of the income tax system what did
you find there yes we found that
fifty-seven percent of americans favored
the flat tax as a replacement for the
income tax and they flat tax which would
be a set rate on income and you get rid
of various deductions and things like
that correct we asked a question
addressing that specifically asking if
people favored eliminating tax credits
and tax deductions in exchange for lower
taxes in a simpler tax system and we
found a plurality supported but that was
still only about forty four percent so
there's a sense that people want a
simpler flatter code but we're not
exactly I mean it's not a slam dunk that
everybody wants this or that yeah I
didn't seem to that that to be the case
but we did find interestingly that most
people oppose a national sales tax only
thirty-three percent favored a national
sales tax to replace the income tax so
does the poll shed any light on why that
might be well that's actually why we
have future polls all right good to know
and then what did the poll find about
the political climate as we look forward
to the 2012
residential run well interestingly about
eighty-one percent of americans said
that they would or may consider voting
for a third party or independent
presidential candidate in 2012 but i
feel like i should be clear about what
this means in the American electoral
system we have two parties and that
that's unlikely to change so what does
this finding really mean and if it most
likely means that people are receptive
to to considering non-traditional
candidates just you know that the mold
of the democratic candidate or the mold
of the Republican candidate isn't the
only kind of candidate they would
consider now in terms of voting that's a
different story in terms of
receptiveness and considerations that
this is actually quite interesting is it
safe to say that I mean there's a this
might reflect a sense of exhaustion with
the [ __ ] live with the status quo with
the political status quo people are
interested in looking at new new ways of
thinking about politics new ways of
talking about debt things like that we
asked a question of respondents which
party they believed to govern more
responsibly and in fact there was no
consensus and that the plurality
response was about thirty-five percent
was neither neither Republicans nor
Democrats which might be explaining some
of the discontent that is being felt
another interesting fact was that
fifty-eight percent of survey
respondents said that they felt like
there would be no difference or that
they would be better off if Congress
only met every other year well I I
suspect that I would have been in that
camp as well Emily Ekins polling
director of the recent foundation and of
the roop Reason Foundation quarterly
polls that are starting now thanks for
talking to us for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you
you